It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最忙碌的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. knows that time flies when you're having fun, and that it can slow to a crawl when you're not. But why is that? Why does an hour spent watching the clock in a boring meeting seem to take at least twice as long as an hour chatting with friends over coffee? Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies time perception about how our experiences and emotions influence our sense of time. Why does time seem to go by faster as we get older? Is there a time clock region in the brain? Are humans the only animals with a sense of time? Why did the COVID-19 pandemic do such strange things to so many people's sense of time? How does culture affect time perception?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会对数据流量进行降速。大家都知道，快乐的时光总是过得飞快，而无聊的时候时间却像蜗牛一样爬行。但这是为什么呢？为什么在枯燥的会议中盯着时钟看一小时，感觉比和朋友喝咖啡聊天的一小时要长得多？今天，我们将采访一位研究时间感知的心理学家，探讨我们的经历和情绪如何影响我们对时间的感知。为什么随着年龄增长，时间似乎过得更快了？大脑中是否存在一个“时间时钟”区域？人类是唯一拥有时间感的动物吗？为什么新冠疫情对许多人的时间感产生了如此奇怪的影响？文化又是如何影响时间感知的？
And if time seems to be speeding by too fast for you, is there anything you can do to slow it down? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Ruth Ogden, Professor of the Psychology of Time at Liverpool John Moore's University in the UK. Her research focuses on how humans perceive the passage of time. She's published dozens of peer-reviewed studies on topics, including the effects of digital technology on time perception, how pain affects our sense of time, daylight saving time and time perception, and much more. Her work has been featured in media outlets including BBC Radio, CNN, NPR, and the New York,
如果时间对你来说过得太快，有什么办法能让它慢下来吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是英国利物浦约翰摩尔大学的时间心理学教授露丝·奥格登博士。她的研究重点是人类如何感知时间的流逝。她发表了数十项同行评审研究，主题包括数字技术对时间感知的影响、疼痛如何影响我们的时间感、夏令时与时间感知等等。她的工作曾被英国广播公司电台、美国有线电视新闻网、美国国家公共电台和《纽约时报》等媒体报道。
York Times. Dr. Ogden, thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much for having me. Let's start with my question from a moment ago. Everybody's heard the phrase, time flies when you're having fun, and most of us intuitively know that's true. But why does time feel like it's going faster when we're having fun and slower when we're bored or anxious or unhappy? So our sense of time is really heavily interlinked with our emotions. And research around the globe shows that generally speaking, time passes more quickly when we're happy, it passes more slowly when we're sad. And the reason for this seems to be that the area of our brain that is responsible for processing emotion also plays a really important role in processing time. And this area is
奥格登博士，感谢您今天接受我的采访。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从刚才的问题开始。每个人都听过“快乐时光过得快”这句话，我们大多数人凭直觉也知道这是真的。但为什么当我们快乐时，时间感觉过得更快，而当我们感到无聊、焦虑或不开心时，时间却过得更慢呢？我们的时间感与我们的情绪紧密相连。全球的研究表明，总的来说，当我们快乐时，时间过得更快；当我们悲伤时，时间过得更慢。其原因似乎在于，我们大脑中负责处理情绪的区域在处理时间方面也发挥着非常重要的作用。这个区域是
called the interle cortex. So what happens is that when this area gets activated due to emotion, really extreme emotions a lot of the time as well, like fear or joy, then this activation distorts the way in which we experience time. But it's not just that area of the brain that's responsible for changes in our perception of time. It's also how much attention we pay to time. So generally when you're happy, you're having fun with your friends, you're doing something you enjoy.
被称为脑岛皮层。所以，当这个区域因为情绪（通常是极度强烈的情绪，如恐惧或喜悦）而被激活时，这种激活会扭曲我们体验时间的方式。但不仅仅是这个大脑区域负责我们时间感知的变化，我们对时间的关注程度也很重要。通常当你快乐时，你和朋友玩得很开心，做着你喜欢的事情。
Time really isn't that important and you don't monitor it and that helps it to fly. During the bad times when you're sad or when you're stressed, you tend to focus more on when that period's going to be over so you're thinking about time more and that contributes towards the slowing of time that we see. time seems to speed up as you get older. To a child at the beginning of a school year, it feels like fourth grade is going to last forever. But as an adult, a whole year goes by in a blink.
时间真的没那么重要，你不会去监测它，这有助于它飞逝。在糟糕的时候，当你悲伤或压力大时，你往往会更多地关注这段时期何时结束，所以你会更多地思考时间，这导致了我们所观察到的时间变慢。随着年龄增长，时间似乎在加速。对于一个学年初的孩子来说，四年级感觉会持续很久。但作为成年人，一整年转瞬即逝。
Why is that? So people consistently say that time passes more quickly as they get older. We don't quite know why this happens, but it's such a universal finding that it seems obvious that it does. So there's a few ideas around. One idea is that we're not constantly processing time. brain is a limited object or a limited organ. So when we're not processing time, what we have to do is use memory as an indication of how long something lasted. So we might look back on a year. And if we've got loads and loads of new memories
这是为什么呢？人们一致认为，随着年龄增长，时间过得更快。我们并不完全知道为什么会发生这种情况，但这是一种如此普遍的发现，以至于它似乎显而易见。所以有一些观点。一个观点是，我们并不是一直在处理时间。大脑是一个有限的对象或有限的器官。所以当我们不处理时间时，我们必须利用记忆作为某件事持续了多久的指标。所以我们可能会回顾过去的一年。如果我们有大量
that are really rich in emotion and detail, then that tricks our brain into thinking that that year was long. If we've got a year where not much has happened, everything has been super routine, then it tricks our brain into thinking that the year was short. So as a child, your life is just full of new expectations. experience, you're learning, you're playing, you're finding your way around the world and it's full of rich memories. As an adult, life is far, far more routine as we get even older,
充满情感和细节的新记忆，那么这会欺骗我们的大脑，认为那一年很长。如果我们经历了一年，没发生什么特别的事，一切都非常例行公事，那么这会欺骗我们的大脑，认为那一年很短。所以作为一个孩子，你的生活充满了新的期望和体验，你在学习，在玩耍，在探索世界，充满了丰富的记忆。作为成年人，生活要例行公事得多，随着我们年龄的增长，
our memory starts to fail. And we think that this might contribute towards the sense that time is speeding up as we get older. However, some recent research that I've just completed suggested it might just be also about expectation. So we remember time in our childhood as slow. We remember the summer holidays as long. Whereas as an adult, we feel. We feel, like we don't have enough time. We're all super busy all the time. So the fact that we're constantly trying to keep up, the fact that we constantly feel like we need more time contributes to us this sensation that time passes more quickly as we age. You mentioned an area of the brain where time perception seems to happen. Is that the only
我们的记忆开始衰退。我们认为这可能导致了随着年龄增长时间在加速的感觉。然而，我刚刚完成的一些最新研究表明，这可能也与期望有关。我们记得童年的时间很慢。我们记得暑假很长。而作为成年人，我们感觉时间不够用。我们一直都非常忙碌。所以，我们不断试图跟上节奏，不断觉得我们需要更多时间，这导致了我们随着年龄增长感觉时间过得更快的这种错觉。你提到了大脑中似乎发生时间感知的一个区域。那是那个大脑部分发生的唯一
thing that happens in that part of the brain? No. So that part of the brain is a really essential area for maintaining what we call homoestasis. So homeostasis is our ability. to sort of keep a level, calm, biological state. So it's the thing that controls your flight or your fight reaction to any situation. So the insular cortex will activate when homeostasis is disrupted. So when we're under threat or when we are in danger because we are ill, for example, and it will try to regulate our nervous system to improve our chances of survive. So the reason that the anterior interior cortex is so important in emotional distortions to time is because of this flight fight mechanism.
事情吗？不是。那个大脑区域对于维持我们所谓的“稳态”是一个非常重要的区域。稳态是我们保持水平、冷静的生物状态的能力。所以它是控制你在任何情况下“战斗或逃跑”反应的东西。因此，当稳态被破坏时，脑岛皮层就会激活。例如，当我们受到威胁或因为生病而处于危险中时，它会试图调节我们的神经系统以提高我们的生存机会。所以，前脑岛皮层在情绪导致的时间扭曲中如此重要，是因为这种“战斗或逃跑”机制。
So when we, if any of your listeners have ever been in a car crash, for example, they might have experienced that sensation of time really slowing down up until the point of impact. We think this is because of the activity in the insular cortex. So your flight or fight mechanism takes over. this creates a huge increase in activity within this area, and this distorts our sense of time. People often wonder why we would want a sense of time that changes? Why would we not want to have a clock in our brain that always gives us a super accurate representation of time? Why is it helpful to have a sense of time that changes? And we think, we're not sure, but we think it's probably something that's developed over our evolution.
所以，如果你的任何听众曾经经历过车祸，他们可能体验过在撞击前那一刻时间真的变慢了的感觉。我们认为这是因为脑岛皮层的活动。所以你的“战斗或逃跑”机制接管了。这导致该区域内的活动大幅增加，从而扭曲了我们的时间感。人们经常想知道，为什么我们想要一种会改变的时间感？为什么我们不想在大脑中拥有一个总是给我们提供超准确时间表示的时钟？拥有会改变的时间感有什么帮助？我们认为，虽然不确定，但我们认为这可能是我们在进化过程中发展出来的。
So maybe if you think back to times when people were living in caves and there were a lot of predators that affected the chance of survival, having that little bit of extra time when you're under threat to make a decision was likely one of the factors that influenced whether you survived or whether you died. So this has provided some sort of evolutionary benefit that aids survival. I mentioned in my intro the question of whether humans are the only animals that experience time. And I ask that because I have a dog and basically every day at about 4.30, she knows it's time for dinner. How do other animals know that do they perceive time? So I think it's a super interesting question and it gets to the heart of what time is for us. So for humans, time is this emotional, contextual experience that is built out of our environment.
所以，如果你回想人们住在洞穴里、有很多捕食者影响生存机会的时代，当你受到威胁时，拥有那一点点额外的时间来做出决定，很可能是影响你生存还是死亡的因素之一。因此，这提供了一种有助于生存的进化益处。我在开场白中提到了人类是否是唯一体验时间的动物的问题。我问这个问题是因为我有一只狗，基本上每天大约 4:30，她就知道该吃晚饭了。其他动物怎么知道的？它们感知时间吗？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，它触及了时间对我们意味着什么的核心。对人类来说，时间是一种建立在我们环境之上的情感、情境体验。
And that's why it distorts going faster or slower in different situations. But our ability to know when something is going to happen, so like when it's 430, it's dinner time, could partly be driven by our biological clock, so the rhythms in which we eat, and this would apply to other animals. But we know from behavioural research that was conducted in the 1950s by Skinner and Colley's quite famous behaviourist psychologists, that even rats, even goldfish and pigeons, can be taught to time. So they did clever little experiments where they, gave rats treats for pressing a lever at a particular point in time after a light had come on. Rats really rapidly learned to do this. So there's something in animals that enables them to judge base situation. Whether they feel the passage of time like we do is a different question
这就是为什么它在不同情况下会扭曲得更快或更慢。但我们知道某事何时会发生的能力，比如 4:30 是晚餐时间，可能部分是由我们的生物钟驱动的，也就是我们进食的节奏，这同样适用于其他动物。但我们从 20 世纪 50 年代斯金纳和科利等著名行为心理学家进行的行为研究中得知，即使是老鼠、金鱼和鸽子，也可以被训练来计时。他们做了一些聪明的小实验，给老鼠奖励，让它们在灯亮后的一定时间点按压杠杆。老鼠很快就学会了这样做。所以动物体内有一些东西使它们能够判断基本情况。它们是否像我们一样感受到时间的流逝是另一个问题，
that I don't think anyone knows the answer to. Not yet. So how do you study time perception in humans in the lab? What kind of experiments can you do? So one of the things that I'm really interested in in my lab work is why do we get emotional distortions to time? What's the relationship between our body and our brain and our experience of time? Why is it that time slows down during car crashes? So obviously we can't put participants in car crashes. Nobody's going to let us do that. So we use VR technology to put people in situations which will create a sense of peril. So one of the recent studies that we've done is we've had people walk across an ice bridge of virtual reality ice bridge.
我不认为有人知道答案。还没有。那么你在实验室里是如何研究人类的时间感知的呢？你能做什么样的实验？我实验室工作真正感兴趣的事情之一是，为什么我们会产生情绪上的时间扭曲？我们的身体、大脑和时间体验之间有什么关系？为什么车祸时时间会变慢？显然我们不能让参与者经历车祸。没人会让我们那样做。所以我们使用虚拟现实技术将人们置于会产生危险感的环境中。所以我们最近做的一项研究是，让人们走过一座虚拟现实的冰桥，
that's suspended between two very high mountains. And the bridge crumbles as people walk across it and sometimes they fall. And whilst they're doing this test, they're wearing heart rate monitors so that we can look at how their bodies responding to the stress. And then they give us some information about how they felt time passing afterwards. And what we find is the people who have the biggest arousal response, the biggest increase in heart rate, the biggest increase in sweating. These are the people who feel the greatest distortion to time.
它悬挂在两座非常高的山之间。当人们走过时，桥会崩塌，有时他们会掉下去。当他们进行这项测试时，他们戴着心率监测器，以便我们观察他们的身体如何对压力做出反应。然后他们会提供一些关于事后他们感觉时间如何流逝的信息。我们发现，那些有最大唤醒反应、心率增加幅度最大、出汗增加最多的人，就是那些感觉到时间扭曲最严重的人。
So does it vary from human to human that we don't all have the same kind of time perception? It varies hugely between people. So there's lots of different factors that can influence our experience of time. One is the variety of mental health conditions. So ADHD and autism are known to influence the way that we experience time or the level of importance that we place on time within our day-to-day lives. Things like depression and chronic pain are known to slow, our perception of time down. So the bad times, the painful times feel like they last a very long time. But what really influences how an individual experience time is their well-being and the culture that they grow up in. So we all grow up in a culture that tells us
那么它在人与人之间会有所不同吗？我们并不是都有同样的时间感知吗？人与人之间差异巨大。有很多不同的因素会影响我们对时间的体验。一个是各种心理健康状况。众所周知，多动症和自闭症会影响我们体验时间的方式，或者我们在日常生活中对时间重要性的重视程度。抑郁症和慢性疼痛等问题会减慢我们对时间的感知。所以糟糕的、痛苦的时光感觉持续了很长时间。但真正影响个人如何体验时间的是他们的幸福感和他们成长的文化。所以我们都在一种文化中成长，这种文化告诉我们
something about time, the order things are done in, whether the past is behind us or in front of us. And when we look around the world, we can see that different cultures represent time very differently to one another. So in North America and Europe, we're so used to thinking of time as like a bullet. The past is behind us, the future is in front of us, and we're trudging forward no matter what happens. If you go to New Zealand, for example, and talk to people from the Maori, you might hear a different tale. So they might say that they walk backwards into the future facing their past. This is also true in other indigenous cultures. So how we think we're thinking, about representations of past, present and future, and how we think about time more generally
关于时间的一些事情，事情完成的顺序，过去是在我们身后还是在我们面前。当我们环顾世界时，我们可以看到不同的文化对时间的表现方式非常不同。在北美和欧洲，我们习惯于把时间想象成一颗子弹。过去在我们身后，未来在我们面前，无论发生什么，我们都在艰难前行。例如，如果你去新西兰，和毛利人交谈，你可能会听到不同的故事。他们可能会说，他们背对着未来，面向过去行走。这在其他土著文化中也是如此。所以我们如何思考过去、现在和未来的表现，以及我们如何更普遍地思考时间，
are really heavily influenced by the way in which our culture represents time. Do we see it linearly? Do we see it circulally? And I think that thinking about this is really important. We live time-pressed lives. None of us really have enough time or very few of us do. And we're stuck in this very productive and orientated culture. If we want to radically change how much time is available to us, then we probably need to radically think about how we represent time. There isn't just clock time.
都受到我们文化表现时间方式的强烈影响。我们是线性地看待它吗？我们是循环地看待它吗？我认为思考这个问题非常重要。我们生活在时间紧迫的生活中。我们都没有足够的时间，或者很少有人有。我们被困在这种非常注重生产力的文化中。如果我们想从根本上改变我们可用的时间，那么我们可能需要从根本上思考我们如何表现时间。不仅仅有钟表时间。
There isn't just the arrow of time moving forward. There's lots of other ways that we can think about time. During the COVID-19 pandemic, a lot of people felt that the lockdowns and disruptions did strange things to their sense of time. And you did some research on that.
不仅仅有时间向前流动的箭头。还有很多其他我们可以思考时间的方式。在新冠疫情期间，许多人感到封锁和干扰对他们的时间感产生了奇怪的影响。你对此做了一些研究。
Can you talk about that? What did you find? To give you a bit of background on the research, I was a mum of three children. My youngest child was about three months old, I think, when the COVID pandemic started. And I remember when the school's closed and thinking, you've got to be kidding me. There are not just 24 hours in the day.
你能谈谈吗？你发现了什么？为了给你一点研究背景，我是三个孩子的妈妈。新冠疫情开始时，我最小的孩子大约三个月大。我记得学校关闭时，我想，你在跟我开玩笑吧。一天不仅仅有 24 小时。
This is like a whole scale lie. There are more. To say that the days dragged is the most phenomenal understatement. And I obviously, I'm naturally very interested in time. And I started to think, well, is it just me? or is a change in our perception of time one of the effects of changing societies as a result of COVID,
这简直是一个巨大的谎言。还有更多。说日子过得慢简直是太轻描淡写了。我显然天生对时间非常感兴趣。我开始想，好吧，这只是我吗？还是说时间感知的变化是新冠导致社会变化的影响之一，
so lockdowns and stay-at-home orders. So I did some surveys in the UK, in Brazil and in Iraq, looking at how people experienced time during COVID. The results were really, I thought, quite fascinating. So only about 20% of people felt like time was passing normally during COVID lockdowns. 40% of people felt like time was passing really quickly, and about 40% of people were like me, and they felt like time was passing really slowly.
比如封锁和居家令。所以我在英国、巴西和伊拉克做了一些调查，观察人们在新冠期间如何体验时间。结果我认为非常迷人。只有大约 20% 的人在新冠封锁期间觉得时间过得正常。40% 的人觉得时间过得非常快，大约 40% 的人像我一样，觉得时间过得非常慢。
And I was interested in really like, well, who are these people for whom time is passing quickly and how can I become one? It was people who were doing okay. So one of the things we looked at was how satisfied you were with your social interactions, how anxious and depressed you were, how stressed you were. These were all key factors that predicted how we experienced time during COVID. So the people who were struggling less and were getting lots of social support were people for whom the pandemic passed more quickly. And the people who were struggling more and were reduced in their social support were the people who felt the pandemic lasted a long time and the days were long and slow. And I think this really shows us that our experience of time is built by our environment around us. And when we have such a massive change in our environment like COVID, it naturally impacts on our sense of time.
我真的很感兴趣，这些人是谁，时间过得很快，我该如何成为其中之一？是那些过得还不错的人。所以我们观察的事情之一是你对社交互动的满意度，你有多焦虑和抑郁，你有多大压力。这些都是预测我们在新冠期间如何体验时间的关键因素。所以那些挣扎较少、获得大量社会支持的人，是疫情过得更快的人。而那些挣扎更多、社会支持减少的人，是觉得疫情持续了很长时间、日子漫长而缓慢的人。我认为这真正向我们展示了我们的时间体验是由我们周围的环境构建的。当我们经历如此巨大的环境变化（如新冠）时，它自然会影响我们的时间感。
How did you get interested in studying time? I got interested in studying time when I was a second-year-student at university, and I actually had a very minor car crash on a country lane near my mother's house, and I very distinctly remember that sensation, even now, of it all slowing down for me. And it really fascinated me. And at the time, I was lucky enough to work with a professor called John Wearden at Keel University in the UK, and he took my career forward and spurred my interest. So it was really just from that one moment that I thought this is fascinating
你是怎么对研究时间感兴趣的？我在大学二年级时对研究时间产生了兴趣，当时我在母亲家附近的一条乡村小路上发生了一次非常轻微的车祸，即使现在，我也非常清晰地记得那种一切对我来说都变慢的感觉。这真的让我着迷。当时，我很幸运能与英国基尔大学的约翰·韦尔登教授一起工作，他推动了我的职业生涯，激发了我的兴趣。所以真的只是从那一刻起，我就想这太迷人了，
and we need to know more about it. We're going to take a short break and when we return, we'll talk to Dr. Ogden about how daylight saving time affects our sense of time and why vacations can feel simultaneously so long and so short. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookout. with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.
我们需要了解更多。我们要休息一下，回来后，我们将与奥格登博士讨论夏令时如何影响我们的时间感，以及为什么假期感觉既漫长又短暂。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候开启夏季烧烤了。Next Grill 四炉头燃气烧烤架特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 499 美元。
This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton.
这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，排除条款适用。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。
Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. So here in the U.S., we're in daylight saving right now. And I know you're studying how clock changes affect time perception. What are you finding in that research? The clock change is such a hotly debated issue. I mean, it has been for years. In Europe and the UK,
欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿促销现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你预期的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时，你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了这次住宿。那么在美国，我们现在处于夏令时。我知道你正在研究时钟变化如何影响时间感知。你在那项研究中发现了什么？时钟变化是一个争论非常激烈的问题。我的意思是，多年来一直如此。在欧洲和英国，
we are constantly debating whether we should get rid of it. I know in the US, Donald Trump has suggested that it's something that should go. So there is lots of research that shows that the clock change has bad impacts on our physical health. So you get increases in horse tax on the day after the clock change. You get more car accidents and things like that. But there's very little research on how it impacts our well-being. So we did some studies in the UK looking at people's experiences of time and their well-being before and after the clock change. What we found generally was that the clock change seems to really impact people who are women. So people who are responsible for their home life, their children, they find the clock change extraordinarily stressful.
我们一直在争论是否应该取消它。我知道在美国，唐纳德·特朗普建议应该取消它。所以有很多研究表明，时钟变化对我们的身体健康有负面影响。时钟变化后的第二天，心脏病发作会增加。你会遇到更多的车祸之类的事情。但关于它如何影响我们的幸福感的研究却很少。所以我们在英国做了一些研究，观察人们在时钟变化前后的时间体验和幸福感。我们发现，总的来说，时钟变化似乎对女性影响很大。所以那些负责家庭生活、照顾孩子的人，她们觉得时钟变化压力极大，
particularly the one where you lose an hour. So losing an hour creates increase in time pressure. It creates increase in stress. Parents in our study described how it takes weeks for their children to adapt to this experience. It also makes us feel like the day is passing too quickly because we're losing the hour. When we think about the one where we gain an hour, so in the morning, we see similar effects. So what this research tells us is that just changing the clocks overnight, it's a bit like Jackluck, isn't it? Only at a population level.
特别是失去一小时的那次。所以失去一小时会增加时间压力。它会增加压力。我们研究中的父母描述了他们的孩子需要几周时间才能适应这种体验。它也让我们觉得日子过得太快，因为我们失去了一小时。当我们想到获得一小时的那次时，在早上，我们看到了类似的效果。所以这项研究告诉我们的是，仅仅在夜间改变时钟，这有点像时差，不是吗？只是在人口层面。
Everyone is a little bit discombobulated. Everyone finds it a little bit difficult to cope. When we think about why the clock change was bought in, this is often misunderstood. So people often think that the clock change was brought in due to farming. But in the UK, it was bought in. during the war as a mechanism of energy saving. So the idea would be that by changing the clocks, people would use less power,
每个人都有点不知所措。每个人都觉得有点难以应对。当我们思考为什么引入时钟变化时，这通常被误解了。所以人们经常认为时钟变化是由于农业引入的。但在英国，它是在战争期间作为一种节能机制引入的。所以这个想法是，通过改变时钟，人们会使用更少的电力，
and this would leave more power for the war effort. This is not a requirement anymore. And in fact, studies of energy use show that the clock change actually increases energy use. So I think what our research combined with the health research and the energy use research suggests is maybe it is time to abandon this random change in time, maybe we do need to have a wholesale conversation about who is impacted by this and what the benefits really are. Because I think at population level,
这会为战争努力留下更多的电力。这不再是一个要求了。事实上，能源使用研究表明，时钟变化实际上增加了能源使用。所以我认为我们的研究结合健康研究和能源使用研究表明，也许是时候放弃这种随机的时间变化了，也许我们确实需要进行一次全面的对话，讨论谁受到了影响，以及真正的好处是什么。因为我认为在人口层面，
we're struggling to see the benefits and the research is also suggesting that this might not be something that we need to do. It's interesting, though, that a single hour's difference has that much impact. I mean, if I just decided instead of getting up at six every morning, I'm going to get up at seven or five, I mean, would that make? my whole world, topsy-turvy? I think this is a really interesting question, isn't it? And I think that when the issue is in position, so time is always used as a form of power. It's like an invisible power that people don't think about. When you're made to wait, that's someone using time as power against you. The clock change is essentially a form of power. So the government
我们很难看到好处，研究也表明这可能不是我们需要做的事情。不过，一个小时的差异有那么大的影响，这很有趣。我的意思是，如果我决定每天早上不是 6 点起床，而是 7 点或 5 点，我的意思是，那会使我的整个世界天翻地覆吗？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，不是吗？我认为当问题是强加的时候，时间总是被用作一种权力的形式。它就像一种人们不考虑的隐形权力。当你被迫等待时，那是有人在利用时间作为权力来对付你。时钟变化本质上是一种权力形式。所以政府
enforces a change in time on the population. So the example you just gave of, well, if I just stay in bed for an extra hour or I get up an extra hour earlier, is that going to leave me confused? Is it going to leave me discombobulated? Well, it may or it may not, but there will have been an element of choice on your part in that decision. So you might have been responding to your own biological need for more sleep or less sleep or excitement about an event. What happens with the clock changes that it is imposed upon us? And we find that in position very, very difficult to deal with. So the combination of different elements apply here, it's the lack of choice and it's also the impact on time and well-being that need to be considered. Now, you've looked at how extreme isolation affects time perception. For example, among astronauts on space missions or researchers in Antarctica.
对人口强制执行时间变化。所以你刚才给出的例子，好吧，如果我多睡一小时或者早起一小时，我会感到困惑吗？我会感到不知所措吗？好吧，可能会，也可能不会，但你在那个决定中会有你自己的选择因素。所以你可能是在回应你自己对更多睡眠或更少睡眠的生物需求，或者对某件事的兴奋。时钟变化发生的情况是它被强加给我们。我们发现这种强加非常非常难以处理。所以这里适用的不同元素的组合，是缺乏选择，也是对时间和幸福感的影响，这些都需要考虑。现在，你研究了极端隔离如何影响时间感知。例如，在太空任务中的宇航员或南极洲的研究人员中。
And intuitively, people would think that isolation would make time go more slowly, but that's not necessarily what you found, is it? Yeah, I mean, it was surprising to us as well. So we were very lucky to be involved with the European Space Agency, the Argentinian Antarctic Institute, or more recently SpaceX, looking at how extreme environments affect our experience of time. So every year, countries across the world send scientists and citizens to go and live on the Antarctic continent for 12 months. So the European Space Agency sends about 18 people and they stay there. just the 18 of them at a base called Concordia for 12 months. Half of this time it's dark. They can't see anything outside. It's freezing cold. The wind is terrible. It's the most isolated place in the world.
凭直觉，人们会认为隔离会让时间过得更慢，但那不一定是你发现的，对吧？是的，这对我们来说也很惊讶。所以我们非常幸运能参与欧洲航天局、阿根廷南极研究所，或者最近的 SpaceX，研究极端环境如何影响我们的时间体验。所以每年，世界各国的国家都会派遣科学家和公民去南极大陆生活 12 个月。所以欧洲航天局派遣了大约 18 个人，他们待在那里。只有他们 18 个人在一个叫康考迪亚的基地待 12 个月。这段时间有一半是黑暗的。他们在外面什么也看不见。天气冷得要命。风很可怕。这是世界上最孤立的地方。
We were interested in, well, how does time pass well as they're there? Our instinct was that it would pass very slowly, that they would be bored, and it would feel like lots longer than a year. But when we looked at the data that we got from them, it's quite the opposite. The period flies by. these people are extraordinarily busy. They are constantly doing research or other types of tasks. And I think that the fact that even in that type of environment,
我们感兴趣的是，好吧，当他们在那里时，时间是如何流逝的？我们的直觉是它会过得非常慢，他们会感到无聊，感觉比一年长得多。但当我们查看从他们那里得到的数据时，情况恰恰相反。这段时间飞逝而过。这些人非常忙碌。他们一直在做研究或其他类型的任务。我认为，即使在这种类型的环境中，
you can make time pass quickly if you fill your days, if you have a structure, if you have a routine, if you give yourself objectives, that tells us a lot about how we can change our experience of time in our own normal day-to-day lives. So if you don't like the way that time is passing for you, if you feel like it's too slow, then there are things you can do to speed it up. Similarly, if you feel like you've not got enough time, then maybe there are things you can do to slow it down,
如果你充实你的日子，如果你有结构，如果你有例行公事，如果你给自己目标，你就能让时间过得很快，这告诉了我们很多关于我们如何在自己正常的日常生活中改变时间体验的信息。所以如果你不喜欢时间对你流逝的方式，如果你觉得它太慢了，那么你可以做一些事情来加速它。同样，如果你觉得你的时间不够用，那么也许你可以做一些事情来减慢它，
perhaps changing your routine a little bit or changing the structure of your day. You mentioned living in the station in Antarctica, where you have to deal with long stretches of darkness. And I'm wondering about the people who live near Earth's poles. Now, we're talking about big quantities, large numbers of people, not just a dozen people or small number, But these are folks who experience long stretches of darkness in the winter and long stretches of light in the summer. What does this do to their time perception? So I don't actually know the answer to that question, unfortunately, but I could hazard a guess. And I think that part of the way that we deal with changes through routine, we build societies that enable us to cope with change.
也许稍微改变一下你的例行公事或改变你一天的结构。你提到了住在南极的站里，在那里你必须处理长时间的黑暗。我想知道那些住在地球两极附近的人。现在，我们谈论的是大量的人，不仅仅是十几个人或少数人，而是那些在冬天经历长时间黑暗、在夏天经历长时间光照的人。这对他们的时间感知有什么影响？所以我实际上不知道那个问题的答案，不幸的是，但我可以猜测一下。我认为我们处理变化的部分方式是通过例行公事，我们建立社会使我们能够应对变化。
So having been to Norway in the summer, the light is, for the light is, for a lot. a visitor intensely confusing. You come out at midnight, it's still light. I found it bizarre. But there are structures in place to help, so everyone's got blackout blinds. You can still get to sleep. It's not like you're trying to sleep in the sun. You can make it dark. But I think that one of the things we can also look at within those types of cultures is how they manage the impact of this on mental health and well-being. So it's very difficult to get hold of alcohol in places like, Norway, partly to help to preserve and mitigate the impact of the constant changing of light and dark on the population. And I think we even saw this in our own research about the hour change.
所以去过挪威的夏天，光线对游客来说是非常令人困惑的。你在午夜出来，天还是亮的。我觉得这很奇怪。但有结构可以帮助，所以每个人都有遮光窗帘。你仍然可以睡觉。这不像你在太阳下睡觉。你可以让它变暗。但我认为我们可以在这些类型的文化中观察的事情之一是他们如何管理这对心理健康和幸福感的影响。所以很难在挪威这样的地方买到酒精，部分是为了帮助保护和减轻光暗不断变化对人口的影响。我认为我们甚至在我们自己关于小时变化的研究中也看到了这一点。
So when we asked participants how they felt about the hour change, particularly the one in the winter where the night comes in sooner, people really mourned the light. The light was really important to them. And they really disliked the fact that the light just went overnight, so this hour accelerated the loss of light. I think the difference that we have in the very north and the very south of the planet is that this change is more gradual.
所以当我们问参与者他们对小时变化的感受时，特别是冬天夜晚来得更早的那次，人们真的很怀念光。光对他们来说非常重要。他们真的很不喜欢光在一夜之间就消失的事实，所以这一小时加速了光的流失。我认为我们在地球最北端和最南端所拥有的差异是这种变化更渐进。
So we can adapt and we learn to adapt to it. And it's when we have these really short changes, these sudden changes, just like Jetluck, that we find it very difficult to cope. Now, for those of us who feel like time is rushing by too fast, is there anything we can do to effectively slow it down, or are we stuck with life speeding up as we get older? I don't think we are. I think there's quite a few things that we can do. So one of the things that I
所以我们可以适应，我们学会适应它。当我们有这些非常短的变化，这些突然的变化，就像时差一样，我们发现很难应对。现在，对于我们这些觉得时间过得太快的人来说，有什么办法能有效地减慢它吗？还是说随着年龄增长，生活加速是不可避免的？我不认为我们被困住了。我认为我们可以做很多事情。所以其中一件事情我
always recommend to people is that if, as you are in your adulthood or you're approaching your older age and you feel like time is flying by, be aware of the fact that this is a trick of your memory. your memory is trying to tell you that you haven't done as much as you actually have and you need to remind yourself of all the things that you have done. So I would say to people, rather than having to-do lists, have I-Did lists so that you keep a record of the things that you do. Have a diary and look at it. Read back over the things you've done over the year and you will realize that the year was long and rich.
总是向人们推荐的是，如果你在成年期或接近老年，觉得时间飞逝，要意识到这是一个记忆的把戏。你的记忆试图告诉你，你做得没有你实际做的那么多，你需要提醒自己你所做的一切事情。所以我建议人们，与其有待办事项清单，不如有“已做事项”清单，这样你就可以记录你所做的事情。写日记并回顾它。回顾你一年中所做的事情，你会意识到那一年是漫长而丰富的。
Even things like if you have a smartphone, just scroll. rolling through the pictures, seeing the time pop functions on different social media apps to remind you, we all too readily forget many of the things that we do. And we need to take the time to remember. And this helps us to feel like we've got a long, rich life. But I think the other issue that we face now more than anything is the feeling that we just don't have enough time. Like we live these incredibly precious lives where we are always doing something. We're always. always on our phones. We're permanently connected to the worlds around us. And this makes it very difficult for us to find time for us. It's changing what we think free time is. And it's making us feel like time is rushing by really quickly. So things that people can do are to think carefully about how they're using your time. If you want to do this really formally, you can do something called a time order where you go through your day. You're always, you're always, audit the way in which you're using your time, and then you identify places where you can gain
即使是像如果你有智能手机，只是滚动浏览照片，看到不同社交媒体应用程序上的时间弹出功能来提醒你，我们都太容易忘记我们所做的许多事情。我们需要花时间去记住。这有助于我们感觉我们拥有漫长而丰富的生活。但我认为我们现在面临的最重要的问题是感觉我们只是没有足够的时间。就像我们过着这些极其珍贵的生活，我们总是做着某事。我们总是。总是拿着手机。我们与周围的世界永久连接。这使我们很难找到属于我们的时间。它正在改变我们认为什么是空闲时间。它让我们觉得时间过得非常快。所以人们可以做的事情是仔细思考他们如何使用你的时间。如果你想非常正式地做这件事，你可以做一些叫“时间审计”的事情，你回顾你的一天。你总是，你总是，审计你使用时间的方式，然后你确定可以通过改变任务顺序或你做事方式来获得
time by changing the order of tasks or the way in which you're doing things. But even if it's not something as complex as that, try and think carefully about whether the things that you're doing in your spare time in particular are making you happy. And if they're not, try doing some new things that will. Like new experiences, getting out there in the world, these are all things that are going to help you to feel like you've got some control over your time. And when we've got more control over our time, we tend to value it more and we feel like we are using it well. I know you've written a little bit about the concept of like you mentioned making changes and I'm thinking vacation, you know, how vacation is the kind of thing where you anticipate it, it comes.
时间的地方。但即使不是那么复杂的事情，也要试着仔细思考你在业余时间所做的事情是否让你快乐。如果不是，试着做一些新的事情。像新的体验，走出去进入世界，这些都是能帮助你感觉你对时间有一些控制的事情。当我们对时间有更多控制时，我们往往更珍惜它，我们觉得我们正在很好地利用它。我知道你写了一些关于像你提到的做出改变的概念，我在想假期，你知道，假期是你期待的那种事情，它来了。
You feel like it's been, you know, just sped right by. But then you look back and you say, wow, I mean, I really felt like I was in Africa for six months. when I was only there for two weeks. You know, what's going on in our brains that makes us think that? So I think vacation is just a fascinating concept, and I think it tells us also a bit about what it's like to be a child again. So you said it perfectly. You anticipate your vacation.
你觉得它刚刚飞逝而过。但当你回顾时，你说，哇，我的意思是，我真的觉得我在非洲待了六个月，而我只在那里待了两周。你知道，我们的大脑里发生了什么让我们那样想？所以我认为假期是一个非常迷人的概念，我认为它也告诉了我们一点关于再次成为孩子是什么感觉。所以你说得太对了。你期待你的假期。
You look forward to it. You count down the days. And that can make it feel like it's really long away because time is slowing down because you're paying too much attention to time. And when you get that and you have this sort of, really fundamental change in routine, everything has shifted. You're waking up at different times. You're doing different activities. And this can be full of rich memories and that can make your vacation seem like it was a long period of time. Or maybe it will just be sat on the beach
你盼望着它。你倒计时天数。这会让它感觉很遥远，因为时间变慢了，因为你对时间关注太多了。当你得到它，并且你有这种非常根本的例行公事的变化时，一切都变了。你在不同的时间醒来。你在做不同的活动。这可以充满丰富的记忆，这会让你的假期看起来像是一段很长的时间。或者也许它只是坐在海滩上
every day doing nothing and that's fine. But that might make it feel like when you look back on your vacation, it was a shorter period of time. And I think that what often happens when we're gone vacation is that as soon as we come back, it feels like it was years ago. Like, for me, as soon as I'm back in my normal routine, I often think, oh, God, it felt like, you know, months ago that I went to such and such a place, but it was only a week ago. And this is part of the problem that as soon as we get back into our routine, we lose the sort of chronology, the order in which we've done things. And that can make us feel like a recent event was very far in the past.
每天什么都不做，那也很好。但这可能会让你在回顾假期时觉得它是一段较短的时间。我认为当我们度假回来时，经常发生的事情是，一旦我们回来，感觉就像是几年前的事了。就像，对我来说，一旦我回到正常的例行公事中，我经常想，哦，天哪，感觉就像，你知道，几个月前我去了某某地方，但那只是一周前。这是问题的一部分，一旦我们回到我们的例行公事中，我们就失去了那种时间顺序，我们做事的方式。这会让我们觉得最近发生的事情在很久以前。
So part of the reason that vacations can often feel like they were a long time ago, even if they were very recent, is that we all live these heavily routineed lives. We like to think that we're all individual free spirits, but the reality is very different. We're highly routine. And this is part of the reason that COVID had such a massive impact on our sense of time. Our routines went out of the window. When you're thinking about holidays, you can try and make them longer by filling them with activities. So you can have this long list of things that you want to do, sites you want to go and see, create loads and loads of rich memories,
所以假期经常感觉它们在很久以前的部分原因，即使它们非常近，是我们都过着这些高度例行公事的生活。我们喜欢认为我们都是独立的自由灵魂，但现实却大不相同。我们非常例行公事。这是新冠对我们的时间感产生如此巨大影响的部分原因。我们的例行公事消失了。当你考虑假期时，你可以尝试通过用活动填满它们来让它们变长。所以你可以有一个你想做的长长的清单，你想去看的景点，创造大量丰富的记忆，
and that might make your vacation period feel long. But the problem is you're creating more time pressure for yourself. You're making yourself feel like you've got lots of things to do. And that might conversely make it feel like the days on your holiday were very short and there wasn't enough time. Whereas if you go online on a beach for a week, well, you know, you might not remember very much from it, But at the time, it was probably really nice and slow and you felt like you'd got lots of time on your hands.
这可能会让你觉得假期过得很漫长。但问题在于，你给自己制造了更多的时间压力。你让自己觉得有很多事情要做。相反，这可能会让你觉得假期里的日子过得非常快，时间根本不够用。然而，如果你去海滩度假一周，什么都不做，虽然你可能记不住太多细节，但在当时，那段时光可能真的很美好、很悠闲，你会觉得时间非常充裕。
So it's always an issue of weighing up what you need and what you want from your time. Now, you've studied how increasing digital technology uses affecting our perception of time. What's the link between digital technology and time perception? We now live in a world where we are permanently connected to everyone and everything all of the time. And one of the key things that digital technology has done is it's fundamentally changed the way in which we boundary our time within our lives. So if you think back to a pre-digital era, you had work time and you had personal time. And these were completely separable both in time but also in space where it was in the office, home was at home. Now we live in this very, very hybrid environment where work can take place anywhere at any time.
所以，这始终是一个权衡你对时间的需求和期望的问题。你研究过数字技术的使用增加是如何影响我们对时间的感知的。数字技术与时间感知之间有什么联系？我们现在生活在一个与所有人、所有事物时刻保持连接的世界里。数字技术带来的关键变化之一，就是它从根本上改变了我们界定生活时间的方式。如果你回想一下前数字时代，那时有工作时间和个人时间。这两者在时间和空间上都是完全分开的，工作在办公室，家就是家。现在，我们生活在一个非常混合的环境中，工作可以在任何时间、任何地点进行。
and that means that it often intrudes on our home time. And this is only possible because of digital technology. So we see these really eroded boundaries between work and home as a result of digital technology. But digital technology is also changing what we do with our time and how we feel about our time. It's making us change the way in which we use free time. So we have this tendency now to fill every single moment that we get in our lives
这意味着它经常侵占我们的居家时间。而这一切之所以可能，完全是因为数字技术。因此，由于数字技术的影响，我们看到工作与家庭之间的界限被严重侵蚀了。但数字技术也在改变我们如何利用时间以及我们对时间的感受。它正在改变我们利用闲暇时间的方式。我们现在有一种倾向，就是填满生活中的每一刻，
with a form of activity. and that form of activity is usually looking at our phone. So going to the toilet, you take your phone with you. You know, falling asleep at night, you take your phone with you. Sitting on the bus, you take your phone with you and you look at the bus. You don't look outside. So digital technology, our research shows, is creating these really dense forms of existence where every little bit of time that we have is filled.
用某种形式的活动来填满。而这种活动通常就是看手机。比如上厕所时，你会带上手机。晚上快睡着时，你会带上手机。坐在公交车上，你会带上手机，盯着手机看，而不是看窗外。所以，我们的研究表明，数字技术正在创造一种极其紧凑的生存状态，我们拥有的每一小段时间都被填满了。
Any time that we save due to digital technology, so we've got to remember that technology is sold to us as something that will save us time, any savings that we make, we reinvest in work or we reinvest in time on technology. I'm not saying this is a bad thing. I love technology. My kids don't have screen time limits or anything like that. I have a very positive attitude towards that. But what it does mean is that we need to think carefully about the type of content that we're watching is that content making you happy. If you're scrolling through TikTok all the time, our research shows that you're more likely to think that this is a waste of time, not just TikTok, any short-term video service. Why is it a waste of time?
我们因数字技术而节省下来的任何时间——我们要记住，技术被推销给我们时，总是宣称能节省时间——我们最终都会将其重新投入到工作中，或者重新投入到使用技术上。我并不是说这是一件坏事。我热爱技术。我的孩子们没有屏幕时间限制之类的规定。我对技术持非常积极的态度。但这意味着我们需要仔细思考我们正在观看的内容类型：这些内容让你快乐吗？如果你一直在刷TikTok，我们的研究表明，你更有可能认为这是在浪费时间，不仅仅是TikTok，任何短视频服务都是如此。为什么说这是浪费时间？
Well, partly because you're not having your needs, Matt. It's just good enough to keep you interested, but it's not quite good enough to fulfill your psychological and your emotional desires. The other issue that we have with digital technology is that we spend far longer on it than we really want to. So one of the key things that digital technology does to our phone, particularly scrolling on social media and things like that, it enables us to forget time really quickly. So you might pick up your phone and think, oh, I'm just going to have a five-minute scroll, or I'm just going to play a game for five minutes, and then all too frequently you look up and it's been half an hour, an hour, so on and so forth. So digital technology captures our attention. It stops as processing time.
嗯，部分原因是你的需求没有得到满足。它只是足够好，能让你保持兴趣，但还不足以满足你的心理和情感需求。我们使用数字技术的另一个问题是，我们花费在上面的时间远比我们预想的要长。数字技术对我们手机使用习惯的一个关键影响，特别是刷社交媒体之类的内容，就是它让我们非常迅速地忘记了时间。你可能拿起手机，心想“我就刷五分钟”或者“我就玩五分钟游戏”，然后当你回过神来时，往往已经过去了半小时、一小时，诸如此类。所以，数字技术抓住了我们的注意力，让我们失去了对时间的感知。
This means we spend more time on it than we attend to, and that means that we're even more time pressured than we were before. So technology affects us in a myriad of ways. And I think that we, as societies, really need to navigate how we manage that going forward for our health and for our well-being. How do we preserve time for ourselves that is outside of the demands of work, this is outside of the demands of technology, so that we can maintain our own health? Just to wrap up, what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're trying to answer? So the big questions that I'm trying to answer at the moment, I work on a very large welcome trust-funded projects looking at time in global health. So when global health emergencies end,
这意味着我们花在上面的时间比我们预想的要多，这也意味着我们比以前承受了更大的时间压力。因此，技术以多种方式影响着我们。我认为，作为一个社会，我们确实需要思考未来如何管理这种影响，以保障我们的健康和福祉。我们如何为自己保留一些不受工作需求和技术需求干扰的时间，从而维护自身的健康？最后，你现在在研究什么？你试图回答的重大问题是什么？目前我试图回答的重大问题是，我正在参与一个由惠康基金会资助的大型项目，研究全球健康中的时间问题。所以，当全球健康危机结束时，
how do we feel about time afterwards? Do we feel like we are moving forwards? Do we feel like we're stuck in the past? How does this impact our health and well-being? It's one of the big questions that I'm interested in. I'm still interested in the idea that digital technology is fundamentally changing our use and experience of time and we'll continue to work on that going forward. Well, Dr. Agden, I want to thank you for joining me. The time just flew by. Thank you very much for having me. It was great. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, follow us and leave a review.
我们事后对时间有什么感觉？我们觉得自己在向前迈进吗？还是觉得被困在过去？这对我们的健康和福祉有何影响？这是我感兴趣的重大问题之一。我仍然对“数字技术正在从根本上改变我们对时间的使用和体验”这一观点很感兴趣，并将继续深入研究。好的，Agden博士，感谢您参加我的节目。时间过得真快。非常感谢您的邀请。这很棒。您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube以及任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in. in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered.
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Winerman制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本周，放松一下，让Ralph's的配送服务为您处理杂货采购吧。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件商品。然后，我们将所有商品打包，并在短短30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。
Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Ralph's配送和自提服务，以您想要的方式提供新鲜杂货。现在，您的首单配送或自提订单可节省20美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。